und jetzt das heute schon ein
nicht wundern ich helfe hier heute und
morgen aus und damit einen schönen guten
abend wir beginnen die sendung mit einem
kleinen an zeichen der hoffnung es geht
um die eingeschlossenen ukrainischen
soldaten und circa 1000 zivilisten im
stahlwerk der völlig zerstörten stadt
mariupol gut zwei dutzend zivilisten
sollen es heraus geschafft haben das
berichten übereinstimmend russische
medien und ukrainisches militär an den
frontlinien wird weiter hart gekämpft
besonders heftig in der zweitgrößten
stadt des landes kharkiv einer kleiser
berichtet
der kampf um den osten der ukraine geht
auch am 66 tag des krieges weiter in der
region hat die ukraine nach eigenen
angaben einen russischen militärkonvoi
zerstört es sind bilder der ukrainische
nationalgarde heute veröffentlicht am
boden sieht krieg so aus ukrainische
soldaten in schützengräben
tunnelsystem dass diese notwendig sind
wird schnell klar
raketen beschuss
[Musik]
mit panzerabwehrwaffen warten sie hier
auf die russischen angreifer
teilzeit monaten
seit tagen fallen bomben und raketen auf
den osten der ukraine straßen sind wie
ausgestorben
zahlreiche gebäude zerstört
wir schießen keine zivilisten wir führen
präzisions raketenangriffe durch wo ist
diese präzision in dieser bibliothek bei
dem denken wo ist die präzision
die erfolgreichen angriffe meldet
russland täglich man habe in der nacht
rund 400 ukrainische militärobjekte
beschossen
hochpräzise luftgestützte raketen der
russischen luftwaffe habe fünf
ukrainische militäreinrichtung getroffen
vor elf tagen hat die sogenannte ost
offensive begonnen seither hat sich an
der frontlinie
etwas verändert es ist eine zermürbende
verlustreiche schlacht die gescheiterten
vorstöße haben die russischen einheiten
geschwächt deshalb müssen sie sich nach
ansicht des britischen geheimdienstes
neu zusammenlegen und um gruppieren
viele dieser einheiten leiden
wahrscheinlich unter einer geschwächten
moral heißt es dort
die menschen in der ukraine nehmen
vieles auf sich um ihr land zu
verteidigen das machen auch diese bilder
aus dem norden von kiew deutlich dort
habe sie zu beginn des krieges einen
damm gesprengt um die russische armee
aufzuhalten
das dorf den medien wurde absichtlich
geflutet das verschaffte der
ukrainischen armee zeit und die anwohner
sie sind stolz
ob es das wert war der russische militär
lang nicht hier das war es wert
wir haben kiew gerettet sagt eine andere
bewohnerin
wie deutschland politisch auf diesen
krieg reagiert ist es umstritten zögern
zaudern ängstlichkeit warf
unionsfraktionschef märz kanzler scholz
entgegen jetzt plant der
oppositionsführer nach zdf-informationen
eine reise nach kiew wohl wissend dass
der kanzler dieser reise noch nicht
unternommen hat eine ganz andere strecke
legten die grünen in den letzten wochen
zurück nicht nur friedensbewegte
mitglieder reiben sich noch immer
ungläubig die augen fordert ihre doch
eigentlich für pazifismus stehende
partei seit tagen sehr prominent die
lieferung schwerer waffen an die ukraine
wie zerrissen und gleichzeitig klar die
grünen in dieser frage sind hat der
kleine parteitag heute in düsseldorf
gezeigt patricia wiedemeier und thaddäus
parade berichten es ist besonders für
grüne für eine partei die aus der
friedensbewegung entstanden ist schwer
plötzlich über waffenlieferungen in
krisen- und kriegsgebiete zu entscheiden
viele hier beim kleinen parteitag in
düsseldorf hadern zögern zweifeln wir
wissen das natürlich waffen zur
verteidigung da sind aber waffen
natürlich auch töten so dass jeder der
dort entscheidungen trifft verantwortung
übernimmt vielleicht auch eine art von
schuld auf sich lädt es für uns alle
nicht einfach aber ich nehme trotzdem
eine große zustimmung war weil wir diese
verantwortung tragen der kleine
parteitag er findet in düsseldorf in
nordrhein westfalen statt dort wo bald
gewählt wird doch die ukraine überlagert
alles die grüne führung sie hat sich von
anfang an klar und deutlich für
waffenlieferungen eingesetzt dies
widerspreche nicht den prinzipien einer
pazifistischen partei
schauen der als regierungspartei der
realität ins gesicht und reagieren auf
das was passieren wir werden immer
friedenspartei bleiben auch die beiden
grünen minister habeck und baerbock tun
sich schwer bei diesem thema beide
zugeschaltet haben sich aber früh und
vehement für die lieferung schwerer
waffen ausgesprochen dabei handeln wir
und h dann zugleich und wir haben ob wir
ausreichend handeln wir sind in der lage
unsere position zu verändern wenn sich
die wirklichkeit verändert aber das ist
ja ein qualitätsmerkmal und nichts wofür
man sich entschuldigen muss seien wir
also stolz darauf die delegierten sie
folgen ihrer spitze stimmen mehrheitlich
für waffenlieferungen für das
sondervermögen von 100 milliarden für
die bundeswehr nur das ziel zwei prozent
des bruttoinlandsprodukts für die
verteidigung auszugeben wurde abgelehnt
verhaltene kritik von der grünen jugend
wir als grüne jugend sehen das natürlich
noch mal besonders kritisch und wollen
dafür auch sorgen dass wir danach wieder
zu unserem pazifistischen standpunkt
zurück kommen die friedenspartei sie
ringt mit sich trifft am ende aber klare
entscheidungen große streitereien oder
gar farbbeutel wie früher einmal beim
thema krieg und frieden die gab es heute
nicht
ja auch die csu hielt heute einen
kleinen parteitag ab und die bayerischen
löwen die haben zuletzt ja irgendwie
leiser gebrüllt das mag an der neuen
oppositionsrolle im bund liegen oder
aber daran dass man noch den richtigen
kurs sucht ministerpräsident söder war
baum und bienen liebhaber dann corona
hardliner und trotzdem oder vielleicht
gerade deswegen sinken seine
zustimmungswerte
heute auf dem parteitag hat der löwe mal
wieder lauter gebuhlt alexander tulatz
gehört
endlich wieder hände schütteln so sehr
die sorge von corona für heute verflogen
scheint so sehr spürt man hier auf dem
csu-parteitag in würzburg es herrscht
krieg in europa und die sorge über eine
beteiligung der nato wächst auch hier
als söder mit überraschend deutlicher
kritik in richtung grüne man traut
seinen ohren
da wird mit einem moralischen rigorismus
vom krieg geredet und zum teil auch sich
in einen krieg hinein geregnet aber
viele bürger sind besorgt dass wir am
ende nicht selbst kriegspartei werden
und das wollen wir nicht wir wollen
nicht in einen krieg eintreten eine
gratwanderung für söder der csu-chef der
ganz der unions linie folgend olaf
scholz beim thema schwere waffen
führungsschwäche vorwirft aber seine
eigene partei nicht verlieren darf in
der viele einen kriegseintritt der nato
für die argumentationslinien verschwimmt
natürlich wollen wir haben dass putin
nicht gewinnt und es muss letztendlich
eine gleichgewicht der kräfte erreicht
werden ich gebe die hoffnung nicht auf
dass er vielleicht versteht dass er
nicht weiter vorgehen sollte gegen die
partner die jetzt auch schwere waffen
liefern der job ist es wichtig deutlich
zu machen dass wir sehr klar stehen aber
natürlich sind kriegs provokationen die
jetzt eine eskalation auslösen
falsch die auswirkungen des ukraine
kriegs auf die menschen im land ein
zweites großes thema auf dem heutigen
partie die bislang beschlossenen
entlastungsschritte seien halbherzig so
sind wir fordern eine überarbeitung eine
verbessere entlastung bei diesen hohen
energiepreisen und zwar für alle auch
für rentnerinnen rentner und studenten
und vor allem für die mittelständische
wirtschaft die partei der kleinen leute
das will die csu laut söder wie er sagt
im kommenden jahr finden in bayern
landtagswahlen statt dafür braucht die
csu
und jetzt geht es hier bei uns mit
weiteren nachrichten weiter und die hat
jetzt heizt wolf in der chinesischen
hauptstadt peking verschärfen die
behörden die maßnahmen gegen eine
ausbreitung von corona infektionen zu
dürfen restaurants jetzt während der
feiertage bis 4 ihre innenräume nicht
für gäste öffnen und es gibt weitere
massentests in der 22 millionen
einwohner stadt um die versorgung
sicherzustellen wurden extra viele
lebensmittel nach peking gebracht
in einigen städten hat es schon heute
demonstrationen zum ersten mal gegeben
in hamburg zogen linke gruppen durch das
schanzenviertel
in berlin versammelten sich hunderte und
forderten etwa günstigere lebensmittel
und eine reichensteuer die meisten
veranstaltungen sind für morgen
angekündigt dann auch in weiteren
städten
im us-bundesstaat kansas sind bei
tornados mehrere menschen verletzt
worden und es entstanden schwere schäden
starke böen zertrümmerten häuser und
schleuderten autos durch die luft die
gouverneurin rief den ausnahmezustand
aus das genaue ausmaß der schäden ist
unklar einsatzkräfte suchen nach
weiteren opfern
nur weil es den ukraine krieg gibt hören
andere krisen ja nicht auf zu existieren
der klimawandel liefert erschreckend
viele beispiele nach ansicht von
experten auch derzeit in indien dort
kämpfen sie gerade mit dem heißesten
april seit 122 jahren und temperaturen
über 45 grad sich millionen sind
betroffen hinzu kommt dass kraftwerke
vor dem kollaps stehen strom wird knapp
und es sieht nicht nach besserung aus
was das für die menschen bedeutet zeigt
normen odenthal
der tankwagen ist da bringt das ersehnte
wasser es gibt kein leitungsnetz in
diesem teil delhis wo die armen wohnen
zweimal täglich wird geliefert meistens
jedenfalls darauf verlassen kann man
sich nicht dabei brauchen sie das wasser
dringend zum trinken kochen waschen erst
recht in dieser hitze schon früh am
morgen stehen die menschen schlange ich
gehe lieber am nachmittag dann ist es
lehrer jetzt werde ich meinen kindern
wieder sagen dass sie sparsam damit
umgehen sollen denn manchmal müssen wir
richtig kämpfen um unsere eimer zu
füllen
durst und die sehnsucht nach abkühlung
dede brütet unter der enormen hitze 40
45 grad celsius seit tagen und das in
diesem engen moloch die menschen
ohnmächtig gegen die hitze und manchmal
auch wegen ihr bewegen ist keine gute
idee aber es gibt welche denen bleibt
nichts anderes übrig
jeder leidet aber wir armen arbeiten bei
regen kälte und auch bei dieser hitze
sonst können wir nicht überleben
es ist eine qual auf den straßen der
hauptstadt in die praxis von dr wäre
später kommen immer mehr patienten die
mit der hitze zu kämpfen haben
erste anzeichen sind kopfschmerzen
müdigkeit abgeschlagenheit
gliederschmerzen fieber und so geht es
weiter man sieht verschwommen krämpfe
kommen dazu wenn es schlimm wird droht
bewusstlosigkeit und beim nichts dagegen
getan wird kann es zum tod führen
in den städten ächzen die menschen auf
den feldern vertrocknet die ernte warum
das ist kein rätsel mehr die
temperaturen steigen hitzewellen nehmen
zu intensität dauer häufigkeiten da ist
die wissenschaft klar alles das geht
zurück auf den klimawandel
unbarmherzig brennt die sonne und unten
beginnt der müll zu kugeln immer wieder
bricht feuer aus auf delhis riesige
mülldeponie die feuerwehr kommt nicht
nach die hitze setzt leicht entzündliche
gase frei unvorstellbar dass hier
menschen leben und arbeiten den müll
nach verwertbaren durchsuchen auch jetzt
noch
wir haben angst wir atmen diese gase ein
das macht uns krank ich habe schmerzen
beim atmen das geht vielen so und wir
können nichts tun
das unerträgliche ertragen aber selbst
wenn sie noch so sehr daran gewöhnt sind
diese hitze verlangt ihnen alles ab
ein ende der hitzewelle nicht absehbar
klimaforscher befürchten dass eine
beispiellose heiß zeit in der region
folgen könnte und in den kommenden tagen
sollen stellenweise sogar bis 50 grad
erreicht werden ja und jetzt weiter mit
heinz und ganz anderen zahlen mit den
lottozahlen dieses samstags sie lauten
wie immer ohne gewähr 2 14 20 25
44 48 superzahl 1 weitere gewinnzahlen
finden sie auf lotto punkt zdf de und im
zdf text auf seite 55 6 die
wetteraussichten für morgen teils
freundlich teils stärker bewölkt dabei
in den mittelgebirgen sowie im süden
einige schauer und gewitter höchstwerte
11 bis 19 grad die weiteren aussichten
auch in den nächsten tagen im norden
meist freundlich im süden wechselhaft
mit schauern und gewittern bei
höchsttemperaturen von 12 bis 21 grad
kann man mit leben ja das war es von uns
vielen dank fürs interesse und gerne bis
morgen unter 0 25 etwa gibt es dann die
nächste express und hier geht es jetzt
weiter mit dem aktuellen sportstudio für
sie noch einen schönen abend wieder sind
[Musik]